m
afin d'améliorer de coordonner les
questions liées à la sécurité dans les
transports en commun le préfet de la
réunion et le syndicat mixte de
transport de la réunion ont initié une
convention de partenariat entre les
forces de l'ordre et les autorités
organisatrices de transport une
initiative qui fait suite à l'adoption
de la loi du 22 mars dernier relative à
la prévention et à la lutte contre les
incivilités les atteintes à la sécurité
publique et les actes terroristes dans
les transports en commun si on veut
faire prendre le bus kg les bus vont
développer l'utilisation d'un vilain ce
que les gens qui en ont besoin aussi
autant développer l'utilisation de
glisse mais il faut encore assurer la
sécurité des utilisateurs des transports
en commun mais aussi des chauffeurs le
dis aussi aux développeurs soient en
sécurité qu'il n'y ait pas d'agression
dans le c'est ça l'objectif de cette
convention qui était attendue depuis
plusieurs mois de mai
en dehors de
l'année a bien sûr beaucoup de choses se
poser mais ou améliorer toujours
améliorer notre activité les différents
partenaires souhaitent mettre en place
un travail de prévention et de
sensibilisation afin de lutter contre
l'insécurité rencontrés au niveau des
bus et des gares routières
parmi eux le département qui gère les
réseaux car jeunes qui font plus de
sécurité plus de fermeté plus de
présence c'est facile à dire mais il
faut pour y arriver que tout le monde se
mette ensemble et voir comment trouver
les meilleures solutions
d'où l'intérêt de cette convention qui
rassemble bien sûr les fonds selon pour
les gendarmeries et aussi police
municipale à terme et apprennent
ensemble des organisatrices en pub des
structures qui organise le transport le
département jeune réseau car jaune
légitime on est là pour avec l'état et
des autres partenaires est totalement
impliqué pour que demain l'on arrive à
prendre le bus en plus grande sécurité
une convention qui définit les axes des
changes entre les partenaires en matière
de sécurité et prévoit notamment la mise
en place de plusieurs mesures
il y aura tout d'abord la mise en place
d'un observatoire de
de la sécurité cet observatoire a pour
but tout simplement de réveiller à
toutes les informations venant des
exploitants venant de la gendarmerie etc
toutes les informations tous les délits
quel que soit le débit des lignes
incivilités agressions verbales
d'agressions physiques tout ceci sera
heureusement qu'à l'observatoire et des
mesures adaptées seront prises en
fonction des délits dans les différents
buste en fonction des lieux des lignes
de transport pour pouvoir adapter des
mesures en fonction des incivilités que
nous allons nous allons rencontrer les
différents acteurs se sont ensuite
rendus à l'arrêt de bus jardin de l'état
pour une opération de contrôle sur le
terrain